king kong ain't got on me
he absolutely embodies the rage that he
is feeling
i don't believe that she is feeling a
gut-wrenching anger
hi i'm kira and i'm an acting coach
based in the uk
and today i'm going to be looking at
rage scenes the good
the bad and the in between
it's such an arc of emotion that goes
through leo's character
in such a small space of time the only
respectable thing about you old sport is
your money
your money that's it i have just as much
as you that means we're equal
oh no no we're different
it's in the blood you're nothing that
should do yours
he starts off pretty smug pretty in
control it's not long before he's shaken
and rattled and you just see a quick
look of doubt on his face
and then when he's pushed to breaking
point the build-up in it is so brilliant
the soundtrack
absolutely helps in the ticking along
with his facial expression changing
really takes you on that in a journey
with him
and you can feel the rage ticking up in
him
and his face is almost contorted
by the anger his cheeks are literally
shaking
and quivering with his rage
there's clear conflict within the scene
between the two men
but also between what's happening
internally with his character and what
he wants
others to think of him he wants people
to think he's a gentleman that he's just
like them the sad thing about the scene
is in his action
he proves that he's not what's beautiful
about it then
is his character's realization and how
his awareness
is initially on the other character and
then grows
and sees himself in the room my
sincerest apologies
you snotty little lieutenant can
recorder the code red denny because
that's what you told lieutenant kendrick
to do
when it went bad you cut these guys
loose so when tom cruise and jack
nicholson are first talking the shot's
quite small
and the attention is really focused tom
cruise
is not moving much the intensity is in
the way he says the words rather than
his body really taking over and in the
same shot he
walks away and as he walks away from
camera his body language gets so
much bigger it's so well done and it
works really really well for cameron's
insider
the way in which tom cruise builds the
scene is really
clever tom cruise is actively
trying to aggravate jack nicholson here
so it's really interesting to see him
using anger as a means
to get anger out of someone else
you don't have to answer that question
i'll answer the question
you want answers i think i'm entitled
you want answers i want the truth
you can't handle the truth jack
nicholson
as contrast is extremely still so both
men are
showing anger here but in a very
different way this is a character who
believes he is above the law
and he is a respecters person and his
ego is high and he has a lot to lose
so rather than trying to show his anger
jack nicholson's character is trying to
stifle his anger
he's trying to control it and he's
trying to keep it down until
he no longer can which is why it's such
a magnetic
scene to watch did you order the code
red
i did the job did you order the code
right i did
why are you eating call teen bar i'm
starving coach car makes us ethos when
we want to move up a weight class
what they make you gain weight like
crazy
one of the things i really like about it
is when she walks into the room and
she's
leaning forward and she has this forward
energy she's actually screaming for a
really long time
and it's hard to sustain that level of
momentum or energy
through that sound and she does a really
good job with her physicality of keeping
this forward
motion
[Music]
usually when we think of anger we think
of more deep
sounds more shouting
but not a high-pitched scream her scream
is
super girly and it's a really
interesting choice to make in showing
anger
[Music]
in terms of how much i believe her anger
i don't believe that she
is feeling a gut-wrenching anger like i
think some of the other characters we've
seen
are but that also ties into who she is
she is a very
shallow character and therefore it kind
of makes sense that the way in which she
displays her anger is also quite shallow
and veneer level this girl
is the nastiest
skank i've ever
met i can make it like it never happened
all for the price of a stranger's
address
no
[Music]
you will never see the girl you don't
want to see me upset
believe me oh you want to [ __ ] with me
you think you know bad huh
you're a [ __ ] choir boy compared to
me a quiet boy
and do you like the way that he uses his
voice he really does let loose and
plays with the words and tries to
get his anger out in that way for me it
just doesn't carry through the inner
life
just because it feels a little bit
broken up when arnold
punches the mirror there's a pause
before he turns around and directs his
anger at lucifer
no rather than the anger being the thing
that pulls him around
and drives him towards the other
character it feels a little bit
like he's got the line he knows what he
has to say
and each step is being seen on its own
so you will never
you will never see the girl never's
really leaned into but i don't believe
that
that line's being directed at the other
character i feel like the focus is on
the word never
because the listening doesn't seem to be
there as much
you and i are so much alike
nothing alike nothing i think something
that would help
is if he pays more attention to
the other character switching your
attention away
from how can i show that i'm angry on to
the other person and how you see them
i want you to go to hell
what does marcellus wallace look like
what what country you from
what watch what ain't no country i ever
heard of they speak english and what
say what again i dare you i double dare
you [ __ ] i'll say what one more
guy
the focus is completely there from
samuel l jackson
the way that he's just so intently
staring at the guy he's about to gun
down
it completely pulls your attention as a
viewer well there's this
passage i got memorized occasionally
ezekiel 25 17 the path
of the righteous man is beset on all
sides by the inequities of the selfish
and the tyranny of evil me it's almost
like there's a
well there is literally a target in
front of him and everything he's saying
is delivered pointedly to that target as
well as the gunshots his words
he is very much in control of what he's
saying there's no superfluous movement
or breath for anything
so even though he's showing anger there
is a performative element
to this whole sequence this is a
rehearsed piece
and i will strike down upon thee with
great vengeance and furious
anger those who attempt to poison
and destroy my brother he literally
lengthens and leans into the word so it
feels
biblical obviously it's from the bible
but it gets the sense
of power that really comes through the
way he says fury
with great vengeance and furious anger
and you will know my name is the law
when i lay my vengeance upon thee
cbs2 has obtained this exclusive video
and we want to remind you now that what
you're about to see
is graphic and viewer discretions
[Music]
advised
in this scene you really get the sense
of the primal aspect
of anger there's no audience here he's
not doing it for anyone else it's just
pure
rage just coming out i think he does
such a good job in it he
lets it into his whole body his whole
face
i particularly love the way that he
turns away from the mirror
when the mirror is broken and you catch
his reflection and
all that rage has just dropped off of
him
even though the rage isn't showing on
him anymore there's still a darkness
behind his eyes
and you feel like it's part of his
narrative that will carry on with him
so in contrast to the scene with arnold
schwarzenegger
where it felt more episodic arnold
schwarzenegger hit the mirror
and stopped there and he felt like it
was a moment
that began and ended there so with this
you see the build-up in jake
gillinghal's face as he's about to
scream as he reaches for the mirror and
you feel that energy carrying through
with him afterwards
[Applause]
well there are several restrictions
what's this guy doing around the world
in 80 days
late enough you lighten up look i've got
a major problem
okay my fiance was kidnapped and taken
to hawaii i've got to get there now
well i'm trying to make arrangements to
get to milwaukee for my nephew douglas's
wedding on the 21st
you're not even flying today something
that i find really funny in the scene is
the way he overemphasizes words you're
not even flying today
in 80 days well consumer reports said
that if you make your travel
arrangements two weeks in
this advance we're all flying today
please sir
if you don't get back on then what i'll
be arrested
put in airport jail it kind of comes
across to me a little bit like
a sulky teenager the way he delivers
some of his lines but i think the
ridiculousness of it
makes it funny you can kind of see this
kid-like
quality he has when another person
waiting in queue tells him to lighten up
and he responds you lighten up it's
almost like he's just
having a squabble with his sister so it
really works in this scene because
you see someone who's an adult who's
extremely frustrated
but who's just acting like a big kid
take it and move on
oh frick you really are a wonderful
talker
if black could be made in a way by
talking
you'll be the man for the job sometimes
when people are
doing a scene it can lean into the most
obvious choice oh i'm angry therefore
everything must come out in a really
attacking aggressive loud way and she
does the opposite so now i'm crazy
because i don't love you right is that
the point no wrong
you're not crazy and you do love me
but i don't i hate you
you were just some boy who made me laugh
at a party once
and now i love the side of you she takes
it really light
she laughs a lot there's a feeling that
she's reached her threshold and gone
beyond that which is why there is this
chaotic
manic laughing that comes about in fact
if you come any closer
if you touch me or anything i think i'll
scream
come on stop this
i love the bit when she almost dares
leonardo to touch her she has this fire
in her eyes
and when he does you see the
exhilaration and she screams
it's like she's unbound herself she's
not constrained to the conventions of a
normal conversation anymore it's one of
the most fascinating things to see on
screen
when the power shifts between two
characters and in this scene that is
that moment
and then i think the choices she makes
in it are brilliant
[Music]
helen's taking me to paris
you are taking me
[Music]
are you [ __ ] kidding me
annie no mom mother [ __ ] paris
i love the way that she drops in the
first line
you see everyone around all reacting
really happy
and then you see that disbelief growing
in her
and the decision of when to say
something and she drops it in such a
almost casual way but it cuts across
on top of everything are you [ __ ]
kidding me annie calm down
lillian what are you gonna go you're
gonna go to paris with helen now what
are you gonna you guys gonna ride around
on bikes with berets and [ __ ]
baguettes in the basket of the front of
your bikes oh how romantic
so one of the things that happens
throughout the film is lots of little
moments of passive aggression so you
really feel a release
happening within the scene as she gets
angrier
a bit like the other comedy scenes she
uses her body more
the physicality comes in she uses her
voice really well to go from
really big to bringing it back smaller
again what are you gonna go you're gonna
go to paris with helen now
annie william this is not the you that i
know look at the shower
look at that [ __ ] cookie did you
really think that this group of women
was gonna finish
that cookie she really leans into words
specifically about the cookie oh you
know what that reminds me actually
i never got a chance to try that [ __ ]
cookie
she does really well to stay on the line
of comedy but also
getting a sense of real emotion come
through
and i think the way in which she
achieves this is because
even though she is having an outburst
it's still focused
on a recipient and that is her best
friend
and you feel the honesty that comes
through with that so whilst it's funny
you really really feel for her character
too
oh delicious
maybe it's better if i dip it in that
chocolate
i should have put you down myself
personally you know i never understood
that
why did you judge me why did you judge
me
there's not really any pause or moment
in between
each line you kill the disappear that
means
so it's just this fast pace as it builds
up and builds up to that final
word
it's definitely an entertaining scene to
watch but
when they're both going at that scene
you get this sense of
they're both trying to show anger but
they're not particularly listening or
reacting to each other which is
why the inner life isn't coming through
so much it's kind of interesting because
the characters are actually
playing people who have been cloned
they're not really aware if they have
emotions in the same sense of other
people
and in this sequence you can see them
trying to access rage
but i don't feel like the choice to
either be kind of robotic
or the choice to be really feeling those
emotions
is fully committed to that i think would
have been stronger as a scene but it
kind of falls somewhere in the middle
i betrayed this [ __ ] is
psychotic
i bet you they serial killers less anal
it's an interesting scene because
there's no one else there and that can
be really difficult when you're playing
a monologue and you don't have anyone to
respond to
so she does a really good job at taking
out a lot of her anger on the objects
that she's handling
so she's ripping everything apart and
there's a power that comes with that
this resolution that i'm gonna kick you
out could have started that
company without me i think i got a
master's degree in business
and there was his secretary
[Music]
[Applause]
and it's interesting that every time she
goes down the stairs
the tone changes slightly to almost more
of a sobbing
tone i need you to be the [ __ ]
background in my foreground
this powerful action of ripping the
clothes off and then the awkwardness of
taking everything out the house
gets into this more sad and helpless
emotion so i really like the contrast
between those
yes and get out
i think she may also be improvising the
scene which gets across
the feeling of just raw emotion
and anger one of the things that she
does in it which i specifically love is
when she gets in the car and she flicks
down
the sun shield and then flicks it back
up and carries on
and it feels like because she's just
moving so quickly her body's moving
before she's thinking
you feel like this is someone who's
living in the moment
i love in the scene the ending the
composed
together character that comes across
in complete juxtaposition from
everything we have just seen
as she calmly lights her cigarette and
drops the match
on the car i don't have to tell you
things are bad
everybody knows things are bad we know
the air is unfit to breathe and our food
is unfit to eat
i don't want you to protest i don't want
you to ride i don't want you to write to
your congressman because i wouldn't know
what to tell you to write
all i know is that first you've got to
get mad you've got to say
i'm a human being god my life has value
his character's described as a mad
prophet as the film goes on
and you see the power that he has in the
scene
there's a real life and fire behind his
eyes and you feel the urgency
i want you to get up now
i want all of you to get up out of your
chairs there's a looseness in his facial
muscles
which really gets that mad energy across
to him and one of the things i really
love is when he finishes a statement
his mouth is almost relaxed in this area
his chin out slightly
i want all of you to get up out of your
chairs and i don't think he's
specifically thinking
i need my face to look like this but
there's an element that
is kind of raw in his face it's not well
presented his
expression is so wild
that you really get that phonetic
energy coming across from him it makes
him seem a little bit unhinged
i want you to get up right now and go to
the window
open it and stick your head out and yell
i'm as mad as hell and i'm not gonna
take this anymore
but what he delivers is actually a very
persuasive argument and the public
respond to it
[Music]
he does so well with this because he's
so pointedly staring at the camera he
never deviates from his message he never
looks around he has no awareness
actually of being in a studio
the only thing that's important to him
is delivering his message
to the people
i'm putting cases on all you huh
you think you can do this jay
you think you can do this to me i can
see the stake surreal for him
i can see the pressure he's under and it
all comes out in such a raw
and physical way you [ __ ] will
be playing basketball
in pelican bay when i get finished with
you 23 hour lockdown
i'm the man up in this piece this guy
is an egomaniac he really believes he
is the most powerful guy there or he at
least
believes he needs to prove that at every
opportunity
and you can see him really using every
fiber of his body to get that message
across
he absolutely embodies the rage that he
is feeling he's beating his chest
he's standing with his shoulders back
he's really facing
off to everyone i'm the police i run
you just living and vocally you hear the
words coming
all the way from his gut you feel he's
connected
to every single word he is saying go and
walk away cause i'ma burn this
[ __ ] down
king kong ain't got on me
although he's really trying to show that
he is the most powerful guy there
he's also reached the end of the road
and you can see that
in his expression there's an absolute
desperation
behind his eyes i feel like it's
like a man who's drowning and is
therefore thrashing around
to try and save his life but it's
pointless it's not going to get him
anywhere
i think some of the lines are also
improvised within the scene i think the
king kong line
is improvised which just gives you an
idea of how much he was really living
in that moment king kong ain't got
on me it's the difference between
portraying or presenting an emotion
really well
and really accessing it within you and
he absolutely
nails that in this scene
thanks for watching what other types of
scenes would you want to see acting
coaches break down
let us know in the comments and don't
forget to hit subscribe